have you ever said no to a roll why I'm
glad I'm amazing what was the reason I
few without naming anyone's name uh what
was the reason there is a very very very
very very well-known and well-respected
film by a very very very well-known and
well-respected director that was brought
to me while I was working on Doogie
Howser and the role was a lead role that
was ultimately played by a very very
very very famous and well respected
actor / rapper and I read the first few
pages of the script and it was I
couldn't I couldn't relate to it
it wasn't the world that I knew it
wasn't anything I felt I could bring any
justice to listen I grew up in Philly
yes I grew up in Philly listening to
big-band swing music from the 30s and
40s I grew up watching old movies like
The Thin Man and people like Humphrey
Bogart and Edward T Robinson I grew up
watching Woody Allen movies you know
this movie was set in South Central Los
Angeles and it was hardcore and I know I
have this hair and I know I'm not the
lightest cat on the planet terrified
skin but I just couldn't it did not
speak to me it just didn't speak to me
I'm I'm a I'm a weird bird man I'm just
a different dude and I said no and the
film became incredibly successful
iconic it launched the careers of just
about everybody who was in it including
the directors and I don't regret it I'm
happy that everybody sort of blew up
from it but I wouldn't I would have been
horrible I would have been horrible in
that cuz it's just not my world and I
left Philly and move to Ventura and grow
up with surfers so I'm 9 I'm the
weirdest dreadlock black guy on the
planet I you know of this stuff I'm
supposed to like I don't like the stuff
I do like is weird I'm just weird I'm
not
I am uncatchable no one's looking for me
you know no one's looking for the black
guy with dreads who's really big who
likes Woody Allen movies in big band
music nobody's looking for that dude
nobody so I create things on on my own
but yes I did I did say no to that film
and I'm sorry you said no because you
felt you just couldn't resonate with the
character yeah there's nothing you know
listen when it comes to that kind of
stuff to me you can be Laurence Olivier
you can have that type of talent gosh
what's the age range for a film courage
have I set a name people aren't going to
know it is I would love to think it's a
wide demographic but I think people know
whoa they can look them up if we give
one of the greatest actors in the
history of the world you you could be
that you could have that and you could
be sitting next to a guy who grew up in
Inglewood and knew a guy who is exactly
like the guy in the script and he's
gonna get it
because there's an authenticity to that
you know in authenticity in a lot of
ways can trump just talent do you know I
mean there's just something real and
tangible to it and I don't know you know
this was this was a really hardcore film
it was about gangs and it was about you
know young black men who were fighting
against a system that was working
against them on a consistent basis on
the streets police you know all of that
and I'm not saying sitting here saying
that I've had this like rosy peachy life
and you know police send me chocolates
and whatnot but I didn't live that life
and I know guys that have and if you've
lived it
there's just intrinsically there's
something that you know about it I'm not
gonna know you know what I mean I don't
know if that makes sense but there's
just something real about that that you
can't touch when I did Dookie my
character was a gang member he was a
gang member looking to get out and he
was slowly actually wasn't very slow at
all I mean when they brought me back to
this show they yanked me out of that
really quickly and I think a lot of that
had to do with me and who I was as they
got to know me as a person and my
character you know kind of got pulled
away from that gang stuff as soon as
possible because there was just
something there was something different
about having to live that life and I
have the utmost respect for people who
come from that and rise and grow and and
creates and
and are successful and there is the word
transcend that life because it's
important and it's needed I'm just not
that guy you know how long did it take
you to make that decision not very long
when you were presented with the offer I
think I read 10 pages I called my agent
I said it's not something I can do right
away yeah Wow yeah you didn't even give
it like 24 hours you just said I just
know instinctively yes no I mean when
you know for me yeah you know when you
know you know I could have gone in there
and wasted everybody's time you know I
could have walked in like yeah well
am i I'm terrible at that stuff I don't
you know
I don't even listen to rap music I don't
I don't I don't like it I get it I
understand I get that it's it's a whole
you know like what's the word it's like
a whole lifestyle hip-hop and it's like
it's an empire in and of itself and it's
transcended in its worldwide and
everybody I know people that only listen
to hip-hop I couldn't tell you who is
anybody I know that I know Nicki Minaj a
but I haven't heard a song I know who
she is I know she doesn't like Mariah
Carey I know that like I know like I
know that I know like all the stall the
beefs I've heard like there's a guy
Drake and he doesn't like another guy
and they're angry at each other so they
rap at each other or something I don't
know the songs but you know I'm not dad
I'm on the Twitter I know what's
happening but I don't and when I do hear
the songs I did I don't know I don't
know I they just doesn't resonate with
me right I like you know I like
old-school jazz and and metal
and I'm all weird if they have a weird
dude all right sorry
as you know I can't
hey it's like what I like man
you